so we're now well into early voting and
we're just days from the 2018 midterm
election it's insane how quickly the
last two years have gone by but at the
same time it's also stunning how much
has happened that it's only been two
years and one of the things that hasn't
really changed that I've been covering
for months in terms of the 2018 midterms
but also four years more generally is
voter suppression tactics and these have
been going on in full force and they're
mostly perpetuated by Republicans
sometimes Democrats and Republicans are
similar on issues sometimes Republicans
and Democrats are very different one of
the big differences is that it's the
Republicans who because they know that
lower vote voter turnout helps them are
looking to purge boater rolls Rd
registering people are shutting down
polling places are reducing early voting
hours and one epicenter of this is
Georgia where we've talked about how
Republican Secretary of State Brian Kemp
happens to also be the guy running for
governor on the Republican side so as
Secretary of State he is overseeing his
election potentially to the governorship
of Georgia there are now growing reports
that mail-in ballots are being rejected
across the country but specifically in
Georgia as one point of of data the ACLU
has sued because Georgia voters in
Atlanta are reporting this is a side by
the way so there's the lawsuits around
the deregistration these are lawsuits
because of a very high rate of rejected
absentee mail-in ballots in the Atlanta
area which of course Atlanta compared to
other parts of the state is
disproportionately democratic and also
has a lot of black voters almost 10
percent of absentee ballots as of
October 12th were rejected coming from
that part of Georgia compared to only
two percent being rejected in other
counties that already should raise some
pretty serious questions but it's not
just in Georgia that this is going on
because in New Hampshire there's a
lawsuit around this in California
there's a lawsuit around extraordinarily
high rates of rejected mail-in ballots
and a bunch of these rejection
might not even be targeted efforts to
disenfranchise necessarily some of it
actually seems to be plain old ignorant
because there's this process by which
election offices need to match
signatures on the absentee ballots to
the signatures that are on file for
those voters but for different reasons
people's signatures can vary I know that
when I signed the back of my credit
cards writing on plastic my signature
looks very different than when I sign a
piece of paper as an example people's
signatures change over time especially
when you vote only two to four years
your signature today might be very
different than when you registered to
vote six years ago or got your most
recent driver's license and when a
ballot is rejected or these signature
match issues voters are supposed to be
notified and then given an opportunity
to fix it or told come in and vote in
person this also mostly isn't happening
so this is an example Pat of at the
micro-level this could be an example of
attempts to disenfranchise left-wing
voters it could be just an example of
how our voting systems are antiquated
and broking broken but it's part of our
voting system being in total chaos and
unfortunately a chaotic voting system
which might depress turnout is not
neutral this actually helps Republicans
and that's why it's particularly
disturbing because only one side has the
same incentive to fix it because they
know they lose when people don't get to
vote well I certainly hope that it's all
just an honest mistake and that training
can help make it so that if the
signatures don't quite align they still
get their votes counted if it's
something that has to do with more
political biases then I think we have a
bigger problem there with our poll
workers and people working in those
offices and and it's things like these
that that make me want to just vote in
person on election day because I feel
like I can then put it in my vote and
and feel more confident about it I feel
like it's just with all these problems
that we have with mail-in votes voting
absentee early voting that's just the
easiest path forward and it shouldn't be
that way well that's the crazy thing
people who don't trust voting
jeans are saying I'm in a bit male in my
ballot I'm gonna get my ballot early I'm
gonna have plenty of time to look at it
at home I'm not gonna have the pressure
of a line forming behind me and I'm not
gonna have to deal with voting machines
that might spoil my vote in some way but
then you have people who are saying
exactly what you're saying Pat which is
I don't trust the mail-in process
ballots are being rejected people aren't
being notified if that's the case I'm
gonna go in and vote in person so it's a
trainwreck because depending on what's
going on in your County at your polling
place you have people who don't trust
the in-person voting system and thus are
mailing in and you have people who
understandably don't trust the mail-in
system and therefore are going in and
the the bottom line on this is that you
have now examples in this election cycle
of voter purges polling station closures
people denied voting all the time in
early voting and certainly it will
happen on Election Day as well because
it always does straight ticket votes on
machines being switched to the other
party as we saw in Texas with beta
O'Rourke and Ted Cruz provisional
ballots being questioned absentee
ballots not being counted we have a
broken democracy and this is part of it
it's not just the systems of our elected
officials it also is the literal voting
systems and what this also exposes is
that anybody trying to swing elections
via in-person voter fraud the way
Republicans claim that the left tries to
do you're wasting your time because
there is no way to get an actual
in-person voter fraud effort organized
that would supersede the variability of
purges uncounted ballots and all this
other stuff like you're it's an it would
be if people were trying to do it it
would be an exercise in futility and as
far as the rejected mail-in ballots
can't we just get email confirmation so
people know that their ballot was
accepted like is that truly so different
it's so difficult to do or are we
arguing that that exceeds our
technological capability and if we are
then those systems need to be fixed
right away I am thrilled to tell you
that one of today's sponsors is simple
habit calm slash Pakman where you can go
and get a 7-day totally free trial of an
app that I use personally and love I've
talked to you before about the benefits
of meditation just simply sitting there
observing what it is that your mind
wants to do has been a great thing for
me we have so much evidence growing all
the time that this is just a good thing
for people to do and one of the best
tools you'll be able to find anywhere
online for guiding you through
meditation is simple habit it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app a very well deserved
award they have guided meditations by
some of the most respected mindfulness
experts from the east and west you can
choose from a huge selection of
five-minute meditations each designed
specifically for where you are or what
you're doing or the mood that you're in
they have meditations for falling asleep
for when you're waking up for your daily
commute when you've just gotten home
from work there are meditations
specially crafted to help people deal
with anxiety or to get focused before
doing something difficult and simple
habit lets you keep track of your
progress by giving you feedback about
how much you're meditating how many days
in a row you've been meditating it's a
really comprehensive and well put
together app go check it out you can try
it free for seven days at simple habit
calm / Packman i've put a link
underneath this video